alright guys i'm sorry i know the
thumbnail for this video is just
a little bit grim but let me explain the
context so you can understand the
situation that's unfolding
between nvidia and intel a couple of
years back
we made a video discussing how intel
lost the cpu race
for many years they enjoyed the bulk of
the cpu market share
before amd started fighting back and
giving intel some very serious
competition
and then at that point many people
predicted that apple was gonna ditch
intel
and switch to their very own arm-based
apple silicon chips
and it would eventually lead to intel
quickly losing market share
then just a couple of weeks ago we made
an updated video titled
apple is finally putting the last nail
in intel's coffin
in that video we discussed how apple's
very first arm-based m1 max
are already spelling trouble for intel
as well as how desperate intel is
getting
to do everything they can to maintain
market share
even stealing the famous mad guy and
turning him against apple
and now we're expecting the m1x macbooks
to come later this year
that will absolutely destroy every intel
laptop out there
and making it even worse samsung
qualcomm and microsoft
are all making plans to bring arm-based
laptops to the market
directly competing with intel's x86
based chips
on top of that arm-based workstation
servers
are starting to become a thing with
companies like amazon
and scale way starting to switch to arm
and the worst part of all is that intel
currently has
zero plans to switch away from x86
so they could very easily be left in the
dust
and now nvidia just made a few
announcements
that show that they're joining the fight
against
intel and at this point they're
basically coming in
to finish the job as you probably
already know by now
nvidia is currently trying to buy arm
holdings
for 40 billion dollars the same company
that licensed their arm architecture to
apple
many years ago and after yesterday's
nvidia event
we now know why this is such a big deal
for them
so let's get right into some of the huge
announcements that nvidia just made
as many of you know nvidia offers an
online game streaming service called
geforce now and they use their bluefield
2
data processing units or dpus to help
their service run better
and i don't know if you know this or not
but bluefield has been running on
arm cores ever since the very first
model
and now they're announcing the bluefield
3 which uses
16 very powerful arm a78 cores
which will be available in 2022 and they
even announced the bluefield 4
for 2024 and of course it's gonna stick
with arm now i know that a lot of you
guys are gonna say that there are
certain benefits to the x86
servers and workstations that intel is
currently supporting
but nvidia has that covered as well they
just announced their new
dgx station 320g which is an incredibly
powerful
x86 based super computer meant for data
centers
using amd's epic 64 core
7742 cpu which is arguably
better than intel's best xeon chips and
then
nvidia went on to announce the new dgx
super pod
which is an upgraded model which is
secured by their arm-based
bluefield computers so on the x86 side
nvidia is already giving intel a run for
their money
but ironically they don't really care
that much about x86
and here's why jensen the ceo of nvidia
showed off a slide that explains how
nvidia's gpus are being starved by cpu
memory
and pci express bandwidth when using
an x86 based cpu one solution is to
create a larger and better
x86 cpu package with more lanes and
dedicated channels to feed
each gpu but they're still the problem
of limited pci express bandwidth so to
solve that issue
jensen mentioned that they could use
nvlink instead
their proprietary high-speed gpu
interconnect technology
which he says is surely fast enough but
here's the main
problem he says that there is absolutely
no
x86 based cpu that has nv link
so guess what the ultimate solution is
if the shoe doesn't fit build your own
shoe
yes nvidia just announced that for the
first time ever
they're gonna make their own cpu for
future data centers
and they're calling it project grace and
you guessed it
it's not x86 based it's arm-based
and because it's arm-based they were
able to increase the system memory to
gpu bandwidth
by 30 times which is insane and check
out this quote by jensen
which shows how he truly feels about arm
grace highlights the beauty of arm
their ip model allowed us to create the
optimal cpu for this application
so he's basically saying that x86 is
dying and they're switching to arm
because it's the only way to go
for the future that right there is
horrible news for intel
because as far as we know intel's future
roadmap is
100 x86 based
they have zero plans so far to switch to
arm
or any other efficient architecture and
that is gonna be
their downfall apple has already
announced that they're completely
switching to arm-based apple silicon
chips for their macs
and even amd the company who is giving
intel a ton of competition
on the x86 side is also starting to work
on arm-based chip designs but intel
nope they like their x86 chips and to be
frank
i'm completely shocked that they haven't
yet announced plans
to switch to arm sometime in the future
literally
everyone knows that this is really
really bad news for intel
and in my previous videos i made
predictions that intel would start to
lose market share
to new arm-based products and it seems
like today's
nvidia event is the beginning of intel's
downfall
as soon as nvidia's event began
streaming intel stock price began
to tank going down as low as 5
but wait it gets even worse because
nvidia kept on making more announcements
which are making the situation much
worse for intel
they just announced that the swiss
national super computing center
will build the world's fastest super
computer for ai
and they're doing it with an arm-based
grace cpu
this is huge for the x86 versus arm
battle
proving to consumers and companies that
arm is now the way to go
for the future of data processing and
everyone knows
that intel is unfortunately sticking
with x86
now as far as nvidia's roadmap they
announced that for the time being
they will include both x86 and arm based
products
every year and both of the architectures
will be able to use and support their
nvidia gpus
so just like apple nvidia is still going
to support x86
while they're transitioning to arm but
of course
we all know that at some point in the
future arm will take over
completely and nvidia will be perfectly
set
and ready to make the switch and we know
this for sure because of this quote
from jensen arm is the most popular cpu
in the world
for good reason it's super energy
efficient
it's open licensing model inspires a
world of innovators to create products
around it but here's by far
the most telling and important thing
that he said for the markets we serve
we can accelerate arms adoption this
means that intel is basically
screwed because nvidia's goal is quite
literally to accelerate the adoption of
arm and the faster this happens the more
screwed intel ultimately is
but wait there's more nvidia just
announced that they're partnering up
with amazon's aws graviton servers
which by the way are arm based to
improve
their geforce now gaming service and the
reason they're doing this
is because the graviton delivers
significantly better
price performance obviously because it's
arm-based
and going even further they announced an
arm machine
for scientific computing using the
ampere ultra
which of course is an arm-based chip and
then there's a system for edge
and enterprise which uses the marvel
oction
you guessed it arm-based but the next
announcement
is by far the most important to
consumers like you
and i and this is just insane nvidia
just announced that they're working with
mediatek
the world's largest soc maker to create
a reference system
and sdk to produce quote excellent pcs
and
notebooks yes nvidia just announced that
they're joining
the laptop and pc game and they're doing
it
with media attack chips which of course
are
arm based this is horrible news for
intel because amd
is already starting to take market share
away from them in the laptop market
like the new zephyrus g14 laptop that we
recently reviewed
on top of that apple has been killing it
with their arm-based apple silicon m1
max
and in fact max sails have literally
doubled
year over year all thanks to the new m1
chip
and if you're wondering why well we
compared our 13-inch m1 macbook pro
to the intel-based 16-inch model and the
m1 was
literally at 66 battery life after three
and a half hours
of performance testing while the 16-inch
model's battery
was almost completely drained so we know
that arm
is obviously the best way to go for
laptops and to make it even worse
samsung is now working on arm-based
chips that'll be going
into laptops qualcomm is basically doing
the same thing microsoft announced plans
for arm-based surface pcs which also
means that they're going to be working
on their arm-based version of windows to
make it better and now
nvidia is joining in with arm-based
chips
so intel and their x86 chips are getting
attacked
from literally all angles and now going
even further
nvidia announced a bunch of other
services and things like jarvis
which are all gonna be relying on
nvidia's arm-based computers
but then nvidia took it to the next
level
and announced their hyperion smart car
platform
which will be using their powerful o-rin
chips
and yes you guessed it their arm-based
and for the future
nvidia went on to announce the next
generation nvidia drive atlin
for 2024 which of course will be using
the new arm based
grace cpu so basically the point that
i'm trying to make
is that nvidia is signing the death
sentence
on traditional x86 chips and since
intel's current and future plans are
purely x86 based
nvidia basically also signed intel's
death sentence in the
process especially for the workstation
market which is currently intel's bread
and butter and on the computer product
side
apple and amd have already started to
bully intel into a corner
let alone samsung qualcomm and microsoft
which are making plans to join the fight
against intel
with their own arm-based chips as well
so yeah
it's not looking very good for intel and
in my last video
i predicted that more and more companies
would begin to ditch
x86 and switch to arm in both the
consumer
and data center markets which would mean
huge trouble for intel
and apparently it's already happening
and it's happening fast
so intel if you're listening your only
chance is to announce plans for making
arm-based chip designs
like today because if you wait any
longer
it's going to be too late so there you
guys go hopefully you learned something
new from this video
and if you totally disagree with my
thoughts on this whole arm thing
let me know down in the comment section
below and definitely check out the first
two parts of this series those two right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]